oh this is a good one Hannah de Vries I
actually think of busy I've thought
about this [ __ ] already what do you say
when you're in a public washroom and
someone knocks on the stall door that's
a creep
that's what she wrote as a creep I I
actually think I've covered this but I
don't know if I have but I'll do it
again
dude I nah you knock on the door to the
bathroom if someone's in there once
that's it do you know why because nobody
has ever wanted to hang out in a [ __ ]
public bathroom longer than they've
needed to be so if I'm in there for and
I'm serious
35 minutes I'm [ __ ] my brains out
and I need to be in there okay you don't
[ __ ] come on hey stuff is coming out
of my [ __ ] dude let me be I got here
first
trust me I don't want this to be
happening more than you don't want this
to be happening
find another restroom or [ __ ] your pants
[Applause]
what a matter of fact sometimes I go you
know what I did once I was in a coffee
bean I went to this is funny actually
because it kind of it didn't backfire
but this is how someone learns and I was
taking a [ __ ] number two and I went
to go lock the door and I noticed that
the lock wasn't really that much of a
good lock I I learn I saw that if you
really tried you could open the door but
I was like look I'll lock it as long as
it goes if somebody tries to open it
they'll see it's locked and they're not
gonna try to break it down cuz they
don't work for SWAT so I'm there sitting
down doing
business okay and I hear a jiggle at the
door and a knock and I say I'm in here
even though I don't need to because the
goddamn door was locked
alright so I'm sitting still going and
then I hear the jiggle again and I'm
like well this [ __ ] gonna make
this door open if he really tries to do
that and again I say hey I don't know
what you want me to tell you but I'm
busy and I'm in here then it happens
again and I get mad I get mad because
this person isn't understanding that I'm
not throwing my 25th birthday party in
this coffee bean bathroom with piss all
over the floor I don't want to be there
alright haha I'm there because I have to
be [ __ ] so then one last time they
jerked the door and this is by the way
not long enough they're giving me
between the jiggles and sure enough the
lock comes undone oh oh and right then I
go from angry to zero angry and absolute
I have cultivated chill mode at the
highest level I couldn't be more relaxed
if I were sleeping because I though the
the anger that I had is realized into
the love and excitement and balanced out
my anger the love events and excitement
that this person's gonna have to see me
with my pants around my ankles and my
[ __ ] privates on display while I'm
unloading okay and I'm happy and I'm
karma [ __ ] dude I'm as calm as a [ __ ]
typewriter okay they don't have emotions
and in walks a [ __ ] 12 year old and I
go ah that's funny that's funny Lord
that is funny and I meet Lord the singer
because that person is in charge of the
world just as much as Jesus Christ is
maybe even more cuz she could do some
[ __ ] the [ __ ] the jeff of the [ __ ]
dude going like this in the park his
Lord can need Lord the singer can
actually do something oh the [ __ ] the
guy with the hoodie doing that in the
park
dude I'm kidding man I mean if you
believe in God that's great believe in
God all you want just you know try to
get them to change the weather a little
bit won't work that's all good just try
to [ __ ] just just keep praying maybe
a you know I hope you get a debt no no
it's good it's good believe in God for
real but maybe I'll help you with car
troubles or something like that when
Lord could sing
[Laughter]